heute beantworten wir mal wieder eine
von euren fragen und zwar heute die
frage von xing kin loop sie oder er
schreibt in avatar fig wettkampf ist in
german is the place of nicht und auch in
essens nicht und auch sind tatsächlich
etwas unterschiedlich deswegen
beschäftigen wir uns heute mit dem wort
nicht wo platziert man nicht in einen
satz das erklären wir euch jetzt los
geht's das komplizierte an den thema
verneinungen im deutschen ist dass es im
deutschen zwei unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten gibt einen satz zu
verneinen es gibt nicht ich bin nicht
doof und es gibt keinen dann sagt man
zum beispiel das ist kein auto wandern
was benutzt das haben wir schon mal in
einem anderen video erklärt das findet
ihr hier oben und in diesem video reden
wir jetzt nur über nicht und wo man
nicht in einem satz benutzt dazu gibt es
eigentlich zwei wichtige regeln die ihr
euch merken misst und die erste wichtige
regel ist das nicht immer vor dem satz
teil steht den ihr verneinen möchte die
position kann also unterschiedlich seien
aber wichtig ist dass nicht immer vor
dem steht was verneint wird und das kann
ein objekt sein
ein adjektiv oder auch ein adverb zum
beispiel hier seht ihr mal zwei
beispiele janisch willste vielleicht mal
dein zimmer aufräumen
ich will nicht aufholen aber du hast
gesagt dass du die kisten weg bringst ja
das mache ich noch aber nicht heute
[Musik]
in dieser szene habt ihr gleich zweimal
nicht gehört im ersten satz hat janisch
gesagt ich will nicht aufräumen
hier steht das nicht vor dem aufräumen
er verneint also das aufräumen
im zweiten satz hat ja nicht gesagt aber
nicht heute also dort steht dass nicht
plötzlich vor dem heute nicht heute
bedeutet er will aufräumen aber nicht
heute und das ist etwas was ihr euch
merken müsste diese regel das nicht
immer vor dem entscheidenden satz teil
steht den ihr verneinen möchtet ich kann
sagen ich will nicht aufräumen
das heißt ich möchte nicht aufräumen und
wenn ich sage ich will nicht jetzt
aufräumen heißt das ich möchte auf räumt
aber nur nicht jetzt so janisch wenn du
nicht aufräumen willst dann mach ich das
jetzt das zimmer ist echt unordentlich
bitte fassen
das zimmer ist nicht ordentlich wie du
willst ich räume jetzt auf und deine
kiste nämlich mit schön finde ich aber
das ist nicht meine kiste auch in dieser
zweiten szene seht ihr wieder das
gleiche muster das nicht steht immer vor
dem satz teil der verneint wird und
diesmal steht das nicht vor einem objekt
und einem adjektiv janisch sagt das
zimmer ist nicht ordentlich
hier wird also dieses unordentlich
verneint ich sage das zimmer ist
unordentlich janisch sagt das zimmer ist
nicht ordentlich im zweiten satz ist es
ein objekt janisch sagt das ist nicht
meine kiste
ich sage also ich nehme diese kiste und
janisch will sagen das ist nicht meine
kiste
hier wird also das objekt verneint und
zwar diese ganze phrase meine kiste
wird verneint nicht meine kiste übrigens
wenn ihr mehr zu diesem thema lernen
möchte dann laden wir euch ein mitglied
zu werden von easy german ein mitglied
könnt ihr werden für nur 5 euro im monat
damit unterstützt ihr unsere arbeit und
gleichzeitig euer deutsch lernen auch zu
diesem thema werden wir wieder ein
interaktives übungs wird vorbereiten und
dann könnt ihr mal selbst testen ob ihr
das nicht an der richtigen stelle im
satz platzieren könnte was ist das für
eine kiste das weiß ich nicht ich habe
dir gesagt das ist nicht meine kiste
bisher haben wir gelernt dass nicht
immer vor dem satz teil steht der verein
führt jetzt habt ihr jedoch eine
ausnahme gesehen in der letzten szene
dort hat jannis gesagt ich weiß es nicht
und hier steht das nichts plötzlich am
ende ihr erinnert euch am anfang habe
ich gesagt es gibt zwei wichtige regeln
die ihr euch merken muss eine regel ist
nicht steht immer vor dem satz teil der
verneint wird und die andere regel ist
wenn ein ganzer satz also eine ganze
aussage verneint wird dann steht nicht
am ende und das ist wichtig zu wissen
in diesem satz ich weiß es nicht wird
die ganze aussage verneint oder der
ganze satz verneint und deshalb steht
nicht hier am ende zum abschluss machen
wir nochmal einen test mit janisch um zu
sehen ob ihr euch die regeln bemerkt hat
und ob janisch sie intuitiv richtig
anwenden kann
ja man spitze bereit ich bin bereit ok
ich sage immer einen satz und du musst
dann diesen satz 1 nicht hinzufügen
sehr gerne ok satz 1 ich bin schlau
ich bin nicht schlau satz 2 ich bin die
tollste
ich bin nicht der tollste die sind
witzig die sätze satz 3 das ist mein
fahrrad
das ist nicht mein fahrrad satz 4
wir treffen uns heute abend im
biergarten
wir treffen uns heute abend nicht in den
biergarten umsatz 5 heute regnet es
heute regnet ist nicht ihr habt gesehen
jannis hat das ganz intuitiv richtig
gemacht das nicht stand immer vor dem
wort was verneint wurde zum beispiel ich
bin nicht schlau
ich bin nicht der tollste heute regnet
ist nicht wahr hingegen etwas anders
dort stand das nicht am ende
denn jan es hat den ganzen satz verneint
und auch bei dem vorletzten satz wir
gehen heute in nicht in den biergarten
kann man das nicht unterschiedlich
stellen je nachdem was man vermeiden
möchte man kann sagen wir gehen heute
nicht in den biergarten man kann aber
auch sagen wir gehen nicht heute in den
biergarten wenn man betonen möchte dass
wir noch gehen aber nur nicht heute
ja ich freue mich schon drauf jetzt seid
ihr dran und ihr könnt jetzt selber üben
wo man nicht in einem satz platziert wir
haben wieder übungen für euch
vorbereitet in unserem mitgliederbereich
so ähnlich sehen die übungen aus die wir
dort machen jede woche gibt es zu all
unseren videos übungen damit ihr noch
mehr lernen könnt mit unseren videos und
wenn ihr lust habt das mal
auszuprobieren dann werdet gerne ein
mitglied von easy german auf patch das
geht hier und der link ist auch hier
unten damit unterstützt wir unsere
arbeit und lernt gleichzeitig mehr
danke fürs zuschauen und wenn ihr lust
habt noch mehr fragen beantwortet zu
haben dann schreibt uns gerne eure
fragen in die kommentare und vielleicht
machen wir nächstes mal ein video
darüber zwar und bis bald
ok ich hab' 'ne fliege hier habe ich
bist du bereit
ja ja ich sage dir immer einsatz und du
musst in diesem satz ein nicht
hinzufügen mache ich nicht sehr gut